I'm Paul Teal and I'm a Scout Master with Troop 825 in Houston, Texas.
This edition of the Scout Master podcast is sponsored by backers like me.
Thank you, Clark, for all you do.
And now for you: Scout Master.
So here's one for you. okay,
How many Scouts does it take to start a campfire?
Hmm, only two or three, but they are very, very difficult to light.
Hey, this is podcast number 303..
Well, welcome back to the Scout Master podcast.
This is Clark Green.
Alrighty, let's take a look at the mailbag
Heard from James Chaplin about last week's podcast number 302..
Another great podcast for the books. he said.
Thank you so much.
I especially like Chris M's Scout Law
And if you haven't listened to that, I like that too.
That was pretty cool.
You did a great job with it, didn't you?
I used that for my Scout Master Minute during our last Troop meeting,
But before I could use it, I had to research the term he used in law number four.
A Scout is Bay.
Yeah, that one. I had to look that one up too, James.
I found one interpretation of Bay, as before anyone else- B-A-E-
And I also found out that it means poop in Danish.
The Scouts love that added footnote in my research.
Oh, thanks for getting in touch, James.
I'm glad you enjoyed that.
Hey, every week I try to have a couple of live chat sessions at scoutmastercgcom.
These are usually Tuesday and Wednesday mornings,
And if you keep an eye on our Facebook feed or our Twitter feed, I'll announce
when we're going to be live and chatting.
And we had lots and lots of folks stop in to say hello this past week,
including Shane Sherwin, who is a brand new Scout Master for Troop 312 in Green River, Wyoming.
So thanks for stopping in, Shane,
And congratulations on being a new Scout Master.
Hey, if you're a regular reader and listener and the resources we've created have helped you,
here's how you can help return the favor.
You can support the podcast by becoming a scoutmastercgcom backer,
and that involves just a one-time thing.
Or you can make a subscription payment through Patreon
by pledging $5 or more a month.
There are special premiums available to anyone who becomes a patron through Patreon
or becomes a backer at scoutmastercgcom.
So to become a backer, go to scoutmastercgcom,
click the support link at the top of the page
and you'll find a number of options that will make you a backer.
And I want to take a moment this week to personally thank Chris Dietz,
Tim Sherrill, Larry Hansen, Jeff Shoppe,
Mary Ann Crumb and John Beattie, who've all became backers since our last podcast.
If you're interested in becoming a patron,
click the link to my Patreon page in the podcast notes
or go directly to wwwpatreoncom backslash scoutmastercg.
One more time: patreoncom- backslash scoutmastercg.
And I want to take a moment to thank Frank Vincent-Harnley, Ed Bruce,
Mike Marty, TJ Farrell, Chris Small, John Clements and Michael Dormer,
who've all become patrons since last week's podcast.
Well, we're doing pretty good so far on the idea of sharing stories
that I can play on the podcast.
Check the podcast notes
and that'll give you a link to how to share your story with me,
and I've got a new one to share with you this week
And I've also got an email question to answer
and that's going to take up the remainder of the podcast.
so let's get started, shall we?
So here's an aha moment.
It's an aha moment for one of our scouts
and for one of our scouters.
These are great moments and I know you've had a few of them
and I hope you have many, many more.
Here's a friend of the blog and the podcast, Mike Marty
Hey Clark. this is Mike Marty, with Troop 4318 in Adamtown, Pennsylvania,
and I would like to share a scouting story with you.
This week, my SPL came to me asking me how he could better connect
with one of the younger scouts in our troop.
At first I thought the SPL was simply complaining,
because all of the things he was talking about were negatives
On how the boy can't sit still to save his life,
on how he rarely focuses
and on how he often interrupts other scouts
when they're trying to complete tasks.
The longer I listened to my SPL, though,
the more I realized that he was truly being sincere.
He was trying to figure out a way to connect with the scout.
When I mentioned to the SPL that this scout is 11 years old
and he's autistic,
the SPL immediately fired back at me.
but we have other autistic boys in the troop.
My boys are autistic,
But then I asked my SPL to consider:
every one of our autistic boys is unique.
He comes to us with his own gifts,
his own opportunities and his own challenges.
Give me three things that you like about this scout.
Immediately, my SPL fired back
Again. he likes to camp-
He's always the first one there-
and asked to go camping more often.
He loves to hike and he loves to play games.
So then I asked the SPL:
where in there do you find commonality?
And then the SPL said, hey, I like to play games too.
And then all of a sudden, a light clicked off in his head
And I said: yeah,
I said that's the place that you want to meet him.
It's truly inspiring to see these young men grow up.
My SPL has been in the troop for the last six years
and he has truly overcome some of his own challenges
to turn into a fine young scout.
But the thing that admires me the most about him
is his sincerity when given the opportunity
to really try to fix a problem on his own.
Thank you for what you do, Clark,
and for helping me become a better leader.
You can send me your story too.
It's not hard to do.
There's a link in the podcast notes
that'll help you make that happen.
Write me a letter. send it by name
Email. that is folks.
And here's an answer to one of your emails.
Andy Davis is the scout master of Troop 43,
and he wrote to ask me this question:
Our troop is preparing to grow from 18 to 28 scouts
in the next couple of weeks.
Well, that's a pretty good problem to have.
The dilemma is, we're not too sure
how we should handle the 10 new scouts joining.
Should we split them into separate new scout patrols
or keep them as one unit until they've been in the troop
for about four to six months?
If their participation level is low,
it would seem one patrol would make more sense.
However, if participation is high,
having two patrols might be a better option.
Of course, with two patrols
we'd also need an additional new scout patrol, assistant scout
master and troop guide.
What wisdom or best practice can you provide
that may help us weigh our decision?
Again, much appreciation for all the fantastic advice
and commentary you bring to the scouting community.
Well, thank you, Andy, for your kind words.
This is a pretty common question I get in one form or another,
And my general advice when it comes to
thinking about patrols has two basic points.
Number one: what you think and what I think
and what most scouts think is important about patrols isn't.
So to begin with, try forgetting everything
you know about patrols.
No troop guides, no patrol assistant scout masters-
These things are pretty meaningless to the scouts
who are going to be in the patrol.
The second bit of advice is get your patrol leaders
counsel together and ask what they'd like to see happen
and how they'd like to arrange things
with these 10 new scouts.
No preconceived. this is the way we've always done it.
Ask them some questions.
They get them thinking about this
and have them come up with a strategy.
Ask what a patrol is, why we have patrols
and what they see as being the best way
to handle the current situation.
What are they going to ask the new scouts?
that will help them decide what to do.
What's interesting here is a very basic principle
that I think applies to just about
everything we do in scouting,
And that's the difference between leveraging
those kind of natural things that scouting
is based on or setting them up artificially.
One of the more interesting experiences
that really taught me a lot about that
was attending a national jamboree,
And this was ages ago.
People really love those big events.
It's not really something that I'm all that into,
But it taught me a couple of things
that I think were important,
Because when you talk about putting together
a jamboree troop, it's a totally artificial construct.
The adult volunteers are selected according to
whatever criteria they're selected,
The scouts are apportioned off into jamboree troops
in whatever way that that happens,
And then it's left up to the adults
to try and establish those scouts into patrols
And my experience with that was really problematic.
We did our best to try.
We went on a couple of shakedown campouts
and we got to kind of look at what these guys were doing
And I remember lots and lots of papers.
I remember forms filled out by the scouters
who were in the scouts home unit.
We were supposed to use that information
in our observations during the couple
of shakedown campouts
to set up patrols into appoint patrol leaders.
We had four patrols in our jamboree troop
And I think probably one of them kind of functioned.
The other three were always a bit of a mess-
And I'm all about being a bit of a mess and things like that,
But they were a bit of a mess for the wrong reasons.
They were a bit of a mess because you had eight scouts
in those patrols who were assigned to those patrols
in a very artificial way. right,
It was probably the best way that it could have happened,
for given the circumstances
It was still very artificial.
They never really clicked
And they never really got along very well
for the first two-thirds of the entire jamboree experience.
And that was because we had this kind of artificial setup
where the adults knew better
And we were going to make all those decisions,
And we were going to make all the decisions about this
and set everything up that way.
It just proved not to be a very good idea,
And that'll prove out in your own unit too.
You don't want to look at the paperwork
and do an artificial construct on things,
Because the real secret is
is that you don't really have to make patrols at all.
The scouts are making patrols for themselves.
You don't have to game their lineup.
They have their friendships.
And if you look at this from the perspective
of your new scout-
the new scouts that we're talking about here-
they have one thing on their minds
and that's the only thing that's actually important to them:
they want to be in a patrol with their friends,
Because scouting is all about getting to go camping
and do cool stuff with your friends.
That's what the whole thing is
when you're 10 and a half or 11 years old.
Now, if you decide that you're smarter than them
and you're going to make up their patrols,
you will learn.
you'll learn that scouts generally ignore
your decisions and gravitate
towards spending time with their friends anyway,
And what's kind of frustrating about that is
that newer scouts might sit down
and figure we'll make up our patrols
and we'll figure all this out.
And then they see that they've figured all this out
and the scouts kind of ignore the fact
that they're in a given patrol
and they just hang out with their friends anyway
every chance that they get during a meeting
or during a camp out.
And so we figure,
oh, this patrol thing doesn't work
because the scouts just aren't interested in them,
because they just ignore them.
If you go back and you look at the way scouting began
and the way it was set up,
they- and Powell- leveraged the idea
that young people typically choose
their own little group
And that gang was really the basis
of the way that they would form their opinions,
how they were going to cooperate and act
and built their character.
And you know, some gangs can be very negative
in that respect
and some can be very positive in that respect.
And he knew that scouting could leverage
that very powerful desire
for association in young people
and give it a very positive outcome.
That's a very long answer to a relatively simple question.
But because this particular aspect of scouting
is, as Baden Powell said,
the single thing that sets it apart
from everything else,
that's the patrol method.
it really does behoove us to talk about it a little bit
and to make sure that we understand what it is.
I've been going on for quite a bit here,
but let me review.
The idea of patrols is based on
the natural associations that scouts have.
Based on that natural gang that young people form.
a wise scouter is going to observe
what those associations are
and make sure that those are reflected
in the patrols in their unit.
And they're going to do that not themselves
by sitting there and apportioning it out
on a piece of paper themselves.
No, they're going to do that
through the youth leadership involved
and by engaging them in a process
of thinking about:
well, why do we have patrols in the first place?
What sense is there to having patrols?
So if we understand that,
then we understand how we ought to be thinking about:
who goes in what patrol
and how those patrols function.
Thanks for that question, Andy.
If you have a question for me,
you can get in touch
and it's pretty simple to do,
And I'm going to tell you how to do that
in just a moment.
Thank you for listening to this 303rd edition
of the Scoutmaster podcast.
Here's how to keep in touch:
Read the blog at scoutmastercgcom.
And, while you're there,
you can subscribe to receive updates
to the blog by email.
You can experience the wonders
of scoutmastercgcom
through the vast panorama of social media.
Join over 11,000 folks
who like Scoutmaster blog on Facebook.
Tweet along with our chorus
of 1,500 tweeters on Twitter.
Pin the Pultritudinous pictures
that are proffered publicly
with 2,400 other prolific pinners
on Pinterest.
Watch us at ScoutmasterCG on YouTube.
And you know,
if you can't face Facebook,
if Twitter makes you bitter,
you know interest in Pinterest.
You know, put the? U in YouTube.
Well, here's what you do.
You zoom in to the late 1990s
and fire off an email.
I am available at Clark
at scoutmastercgcom.
That's C-L-A-R-K-E
Now, if all else fails,
if you get up on the roof
of your camp headquarters,
you'll find a big spotlight
that projects a special signal
up against the clouds.
Switch it on for a few moments
and I would say you know
three to four minutes minimum
and I'll be in touch.
Well, by this time
it should be abundantly clear
that the Scoutmaster blog
and the Scoutmaster podcast
and all the other stuff
that we're doing
is not an official publication of,
nor is it endorsed by,
any scouting organization whatsoever.
No, it's just me.
This is my way of trying
to lend a hand to my fellow Scouters
and have a little fun along the way.
and speaking of fun,
here he is our founder,
Sir Robert Baden-Powell.
Sir Robert,
Good luck to you and good camping.
Oh, I thank you, sir.
Until next time, everyone,
you,
you.
Good luck to you and good camping.